françois rebsamen bonsoir la merdes
région depuis 2001 l'autre aspirent à le
devenir et ils ne sont d'accord sur rien
ou presque première vérification avec
l'image qu'ils ont de leur ville une
capitale régionale sans dynamisme pour
alain houpert quand je pose mon regard
sur dijon je vois un décor de théâtre
et quand je lève le voile je vois sur
les coulisses un tableau sombre et
inquiétant une démographie stagnante des
entreprises qui quitte le dijonnais 27%
depuis 2001 des emplois en baisse 3000
depuis 2012 une dette exceptionnelle et
une première réponse cinglante de
françois rebsamen du rendez vous
monsieur la tête de liste de l'ump
vous êtes disqualifié pour parler de
fiscalité locale vous avez augmenté
l'année dernière les impôts fonciers des
dijonnais et de tous les habitants de
côte-d'or de près de 13 8% et vous venez
aujourd'hui donner des leçons autre
sujet de discorde la place de la voiture
dans dijon depuis l'arrivée du tram nous
visons souffre d'une sur pied tony's à
sion du centre-ville les personnes âgées
les personnes à mobilité réduite ne
peuvent afflux accéder au marché de ma
vente à nouveau mouche je ne connaissais
pas la sueur piétonnisation on dira nous
parle pas comme ça de la piétonnisation
parce que c'est un moment plutôt
agréable pour une plutôt agréable pour
une ville vous parlez du centre-ville
écoutez les commerçants vous savez
voltaire disait que les oreilles sont le
chemin du coeur j'aime dijon dijon est
une ville fantastique dijon est un chef
d'oeuvre en devenir et ce chez dehors il
faut en faire un joyau et là surprise
les deux candidats sont d'accord enfin
presque de plus des parkings et bien sûr
bien sûr vous disiez quel voleur et quel
bonheur d'avoir fait la place de la
libération et quel bonheur d'avoir fait
la place darcy et quel bonheur d'avoir
rénové la place de la république vous
devriez tous les jours tous les jours
vous semble satisfaire et en être
heureux puisque vous avez dit gens comme
vous aimiez salive ya encore un angle et
une pique de plus de françois rebsamen
pour son principal adversaire dans un
débat ac sous tension du début à la fin